six i sei consiglieri a life l'ha già
detto qualcuno si ok possibili tagli a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video che giornate pazzesche allora
questo è il primo video a riguardo
perché ancora non ho fatti sul mio
canale forse sapete che cosa sta
succedendo
forse non è detto però forse lo sapete
ci siamo ritrovati a casa cioè ritrovati
a casa e anche io che tra l'altro questa
casa qua non è una casa a qualunque non
è un green screen questa incredibile
come successe a questa pausa durata solo
qua a torino non sono a milano io vivo
da sola milano ormai da cinque anni e
passa però ho iniziato a fare video su
youtube quando vivevo ancora con i
genitori
quindi in questa casa qui come ci sono
finito qua ero già a casa prima che
succedesse tutto il casino poi quando
hanno chiuso la lombardia gli ero già a
torino perché io una volta ogni due
settimane 3 circa vado a torino a
trovare i genitori erano andate nel
weekend
e mentre ero con successo il casinò
della lombardia e quindi ho avuto il
problema contrario e dovevo tornare
perché a casa mia a milano tutta
l'attrezzatura per fare video chat
l'inter che perde di aver battuto un
record assoluto nella mia vita è questa
settimana non sono mai uscito
ma neanche in balcone non mi pesa per
niente ma zero ragazzi non siamo qua per
fare
prepara di questo ma un po per il fatto
che tutti ci siamo ritrovati in casa
perché è giusto stare in casa per il
fatto che comunque si tratta di
rispettare delle regole a queste regole
andranno a beneficio di tutti quindi non
è che non state facendo per qualcun
altro sta facendo pirata in primis per
voi e io sono orgoglioso di questo sono
orgoglioso perché ogni giorno che passo
dentro camera mia mi sento sempre di più
un eroe senza fare un cazzo
avevo questo il bello non fai niente ma
se un eroe bello il mio ideale di che di
essere cavaliere e questo perfetto
possono fare un sacco di cose in casa un
sa chi ci ho fatto una carriera davanti
al suo computer in camera mia
non vi si chiede di far carriera vi si
chiede di divertirmi come fai a fa vga
divertiti in casa ma sapete quante cose
si possono fare in casa ma lo sapete da
quando sono in casa mia
secondo voi che cos'è che ho fatto in
tutti questi giorni in casa i più
pervertiti avranno pensato a una cosa ma
non è quella che ho giocato col cane
cosa dovrà ed è stato fighissimo
guardate come ho passato io i miei
ultimi giorni in casa
[Musica]
seduto bravissimo ma che grande salta
bravissimo ma come bravo questo cane
mika michael avrebbe fatto lo stesso no
perché gliel'ho chiesto io riga dai cosa
è meritato visto che i ragazzi perso un
po di spremute d'arancia
la mamma no di sicuro farà che molto più
salutare questa che la ciabatta fiat e
presto a posto un nuovo aiuto si spezza
seduta in mano non ti muovere seduto e
possibil
[Musica]
mi spieghi cosa ti ha fatto bart simpson
c'è veramente qual è il problema
qual è il problema di questo no questo
cane normale e con i giochi per cani non
i pupazzi per i bambini che mio questo
lontano center es.co del demonio e miu
miu
cosa ti incazzi non ci arrivi non c'è
rivinti le guarda
prego
dai adesso ragazzi vi faccio vedere un
po come la faccenda in camera di mio
padre e mio papà è questa questo è un
pianoforte
mio padre di un museo di robe di cose
partiamo dal poster di gain terapie
dopodiché abbiamo un dipinto c'è tutto
su di me tra l'altro una figurina dalla
dubbia posa e dai dubbi i capelli la
gigantografia dell'album di figurine
veramente grosso sta fare cioè poi
lancia anche da tag questa notte bad e
quelle ovviamente sono le mie scarpe io
che prova a fare il cubo con il cane mi
dà fastidio
questa la frase ma veniamo fi incubo con
il cane mentre stia a casa
[Musica]
però ragazzi in questi giorni
soprattutto a partire la data stamattina
perché oggi e domenica stamattina ho
fatto la live in tutte le live da oggi
in avanti ci saranno un sacco di
cambiamenti innanzitutto metterò sempre
quasi sempre la webcam ci sarà una live
al mese pomeridiana così da essere
accessibile a più persone possibili e
non sarà neanche l'ultimo perché ci
saranno altre novità che arriveranno più
avanti ma non me le posso dire tutte le
live le apre nichi box alle dalle 8 alle
13 lo sapete ci siamo uniti box dalle
otto alle dieci e mezza 11 c'è nichi poi
subentrò io quando subentrerò io farò un
recap di che cosa è successo alla sixty
seconds che ogni volta che entro in live
digos ragazzi giorno 12 punti può tra
l'altro che molti di voi stanno anche
facendo le elezioni a casa nel senso che
proprio con skype vi connettete alla
classe la cosa più incredibile degli
orari veramente voluto provare una volta
fare una cosa del genere sarebbe stato
pazzesco e spero che le elezioni di vada
bene e magari salutate il prof con la
prossima volta con un bel a tutti i
ragazzi si sa mai c'è questa cosa qua
per me e e astrale cioè in un'immagine
neanche veramente [ __ ] come una start up
che appunto conosco si chiama we school
che questa startup di questo ragazzo che
secondo me ha fatto una cosa geniale e
permette di unire studenti e professori
attraverso diverse internazioni potete
fare online con green school è veramente
finissima questa startup questa cosa che
potete fare e tra l'altro è anche già
utilizzatissima e io vi consiglio di
darci un'occhiata perché potrebbe essere
utile entrato non solo in questo momento
dove c'è questa emergenza insomma ma
anche dopo perché comunque quando le
persone interagiscono tra di loro sia
studenti che professori rende tutto di
tutto più divertente tutto meno formale
e le cose secondo me divertendosi in
qualche modo rimangono anche di più
fateci un occhiata assolutamente ragazzi
e soprattutto supportiamo queste mega
iniziative tra l'altro italiane volevo
dirvi che in questi giorni state pronti
per questa incredibile farò uscire
diversi video riguardanti insomma tutta
questa situazione perché mi ha chiesto
già qualche giorno fa nelle stories
qualcuno di voi ha già partecipato di
farvi un video di quello che fate a casa
e io farò un video reaction a tutti i
vostri video a casa per vedere come come
passate il tempo e che divertenti li
metto punti in un video che uscirà
questa settimana ieri abbiamo registrato
uno miguel che uscirà veramente molto
presto questi giorni fa uscire sia un
miccoli sia il video reaction ei vostri
video in casa tutto questo per farvi
capire che stare a casa in realtà è figo
acilia questa settimana con un sacco di
video per la temi che oggi non è uscito
è prince ma ci tenevo a fare un video in
cui spiegava la situazione so che siete
guerrieri e so che passerete alla storia
per essere eroi perché lo state
diventando non facendo un cazzo
[Musica]